if biology created a few hacks on top of
which Consciousness and cognition and
some of the things we love about human
beings was created it makes you wonder
what kind of
Beauty in the complexity yeah there's
there's an early peek at that which is
um there's a misleading term which is
generative design
generative design is where you don't
tell a computer how to design something
you tell the computer what you want it
to do that doesn't work that only works
in limited subdomains you can't do
really complex functionality that way
the one place that's matured though is
topology optimization for structure so
let's say you wanted to make a bicycle
or a table
you describe the loads on it and it
figures out how to design it and what it
makes are beautiful organic looking
things these are things that look like
they grew in a forest and
they look like they grew in a forest
because that's sort of exactly what they
are that they're they're they're solving
the ways of how you handle loads in the
same way biology does and so you get
things that look like trees and shells
and all of that and so that's a Peak at
this transition to
um from we we design to to we teach the
machines how to design what can you say
about because you mentioned cellular
automata earlier about from this example
you just gave and in general the
observation you can make by looking at
cellular automata that there's a
from simple rules and simple building
blocks can emerge arbitrary complexity
do we understand like do you understand
what that is how that can be leveraged
so understand what it is is much easier
than it sounds I complained about
turing's machine making a physics
mistake but Turing never intended it to
be a computer architecture he used it
just to prove uh results about
uncomputability
um what what Turing did on what his
computation is exquisite it's gorgeous
um he gave us our notion of
computational universality and something
that sounds deep and turns out to be
trivial is
it's really easy to show almost
everything as computationally universal
so Norm margulis wrote a beautiful paper
um with Tom tofully showing in a
cellular a cellular automatic world is
like The Game of Life where you just
move tokens around
um they showed that modeling billiard
balls on a billiard table with cellular
automata is a universal computer
to be Universal you need a persistent
state
you need a non-linear operation to
interact them
and you need connectivity
so that's what you need to show
computational universality so they
showed that a CA modeling billiard balls
is a universal computer
um Chris Moore went on to show that
instead of chaos let's see
um Turing showed their computable their
problems in computation that you can't
solve
that they're harder than you can't
predict they're actually in a deep
reason they are unsolvable
um Chris Moore showed it's very easy to
make physical systems that are
uncomputable that what what the physics
system does
just bouncing balls and surfaces you can
make systems that solve uncomputable
problems and so almost any non-trivial
physical system is computationally
universal
so the first part of the answer to your
question is you know this comes back to
how you know my comment about how do you
bootstrap a civilization you just don't
need much to be computationally
Universal so then
there isn't today a notion of like
fabricational universality or
fabricational complexity the sort of
numbers I've been giving you about you
eating lunch versus the chip Fab sort of
that that that's in the same Spirit of
what Shannon did but once you connect
computational
universality to kind of fabricational
universality you then get the ability to
grow and adapt and evolve
because that Evolution happens in the
physical space yeah and so that's why
you know for me the heart of this whole
conversation is morphogenesis so just to
come back to that
um
what Turing
ended his sadly cut short life
studying
was how genes give rise to form so so
how the the the small amount of it
relatively in effect small amount of
information in the genome can give rise
to the complexity of Who You Are
and and that that that's where
it what resides is this molecular
intelligence
which is first how to describe you but
then how to describe you such that you
can exist and you can reproduce and you
can grow and you can evolve
and so you know that that's the seat of
our molecular intelligence
the make a revolution in biology yeah it
really is
um it really is and and that that's
where you can't separate communication
computation and Fabrication you can't
separate computer science and physical
science you can't separate hardware and
software they all intersect right at
that place